interpreting interpreting actually is
the right title for this because what
we're doing is this kind of thing you've
been seeing for years now right and
you've been learning to explain it in
and articulate in calculus language with
quite some time but what we do want to
do is work out what does it mean
that's interpretation what does it mean
in physical terms in motion terms okay
so they have all these quickfire
questions and we're going to march
through them really quickly just by
looking at the graph just by looking the
graph which is why it's so important
that you have a decent sized graph of
which you can interpret list so let me
read the preamble a particle is moving
horizontally so that it's displacement X
meters to the right of the origin I'm
just gonna pause there for a second
it's not necessary but it's certainly
useful if you put like information onto
the graph that'll help you interpret
this properly right so number one add
displacement right number one it's in
meters but they also give you a
direction don't they it's not up down
it's not back for it's to the right okay
and that's the positive direction so I
actually put that on my diagram it's
displacement X meters to the right of
the origin so this this horizontal line
here represents the origin at different
points in time okay is given by the
graph to the right enemies are seconds
okay good now let's start to walk
through the questions the first thing
they ask is what's the maximum distance
away from the origin in the first ten
seconds okay now being that we just said
we just established that this horizontal
line the time axis that represents where
the origin is at different points in
time okay there's the first ten seconds
okay
so where are you where's your maximum
distance is where is your greatest value
further away okay now it just so happens
in this ground that there are no values
that are negative okay but it wouldn't
matter if you were to the left or to the
right if they say maximum distance okay
they just want to know where are you
furthest so what is the maximum distance
they give it to on the graph right it's
eight meters bigger
that's all you have to say and you say
from the rap that's that's your only
reason to because it's drawn like that
when does it occur well we're really
times off of this horizontal axis right
so you could say eight meters at time
equals three be careful sometimes and we
looked at this last exercise right
sometimes questions will say after three
seconds or during the third second you
have to be very very cautious with your
words there say at T equals three as
much say [ __ ] because look it's a point
it's at that point right Sukey Sukey you
could say after three seconds but I try
to avoid using that language as much as
I can because it's so confusing okay I
might rather actually provide that's
that's a time that's enough then they
asked some questions about its velocity
okay so where's the particle stationary
went at me right went at moving left
okay here's where you're gonna help me
now notice that this is to the right
okay so literally what you could do is
you can look at this thing sideways like
if you turn your head 90 degrees to the
left okay you can actually see it so
when you're looking at it or you
alternately you can turn your page
literally you're going to the right and
you're going to the left you're going to
the right again okay so do these things
to make the interpretation sit before
you being it with sideways right now
let's do these two first wait am i
moving to the right here I am let me let
me put it in green okay look see I'm
moving to the right here okay like it
looks to the right right okay so between
time 0 and time 3 there's my first one
okay then I turn around but where's the
next time that I turn to the right will
here moving to the right again and
forever okay so you can see from time 0
to time 3 and from time 9 onwards okay
and so you want to express that as an
inequality so I guess you would say what
did you say to the right 0 2 3 and
greater than notice okay moving to the
left is the only other option in this
running out of colors okay look here we
go moving to the left you can literally
see it okay and so it's just between
three and nine okay we can put it back
now I think people are going to get
confused enough there you go I've done
my right and my left is very easy to get
them confused okay all usually the
points were at stationary we're quite
good at this we don't need to turn our
head sideways to see this you've got two
stationary points number one number two
okay so wait is it stationary
where time equals three and we're tired
equals good and there you go it's as
simple as that read off the graph make
your graph good enough so that you can
see okay Part C where does the it's a PI
positive yeah when does the party core
return to the origin at that time where
is it
what is its velocity and in what
direction is accelerating okay now let's
talk about acceleration in a second well
answer this one simply when does your
turn to the origin starts there right it
goes through the right and then it comes
back to the left and it's time nine
right so you can say that's when it
returns okay now it doesn't have to be
but in this case that happens to also be
a stationary point so it's velocity at
that point is zero good now they then
pose the question in which direction are
you accelerating okay now that's where I
want to remind you that we've got a
displacement right we've got velocity
velocity but that's how displacement
changing over time right so our calculus
expression for that is DX over DT and of
course therefore acceleration by
extension is the second derivative isn't
it so you've got d squared X DT squared
okay
so therefore rather than like country
the numbers are getting confused about
the direction use the intuition you
already have from what you know about
calculus right to answer this question
they want to know what direction is the
acceleration in what direction so what
you want to think about is this guy
and which way he is facing okay now you
already know what second really is me
when it comes to graphs they are
geometric feature what kind of geometric
feature is it what kind of quality
attribute first are you tells you
gradient second tells you concavity
exactly right okay so you want to think
about when you're trying to understand
acceleration you look at the concave 'ti
of the graph okay now we said it's at
time line where you've got your
stationary point and the direction of
the concavity is well it's that way on
my graph which I have labeled as to the
right that make sense okay
I mean obviously the way you would say
that in terms of numbers is that the
second derivative is positive but we've
already defined positive as to the right
okay so therefore I would say it's
acceleration is to the right do not take
up there is no up in this situation okay
it's only straight-line one dimensional
left right okay next where's the
acceleration equal to zero well again
I'm going to come back to this
understanding right it's about concavity
it's about the second derivative right
where is the acceleration zero is the
same as saying where is the second
derivative zero which is the same as
saying what kind of point is that that's
a point of inflection and we're really
good at fine points of inflection right
where is it on this graph it's there at
six
isn't it and you can almost even see it
like concavity is about curvature right
and at that point it's it's tending
toward a straight line that's why
there's no concavity bit here concave
down acceleration to the left
Hyup concave up acceleration to the
right there
it's not accelerating yours it's not
accelerating any direction okay so
acceleration zero at time equals six we
could already say that where are we at
that point where well no let me just
look at how they worded it it says where
is it then so really rather than saying
x equals four right I should really say
four meters to the right they don't ask
for the value of a pronumeral variable
they ask for where I so you should
provide that in language that
they've given you four meters to the
right and then they say and in what
direction is it moving which way is it
going
we already labeled this didn't we it's
moving to that great timing it's a bit
to the left
is it okay okay so just like I said for
where you described displacement you
should give it as words you should say
that in in regards to the velocities or
don't say velocities negative they say
which direction am i moving in so you
give them a direction that's all right
okay where we going
when is the acceleration negative we've
already answered this haven't we we want
to think about concavity okay so it's
this part here that's the part of the
graph that's concave down so it's
between 0 & 6 okay hmm by the looks of
it it includes that boundary times 0
actually well you don't really know do
you yeah you don't know that's a bit
sneaky bb-but I don't know I better not
say that it is but they would probably
give you more information they might
give you an actual displacement time
equation and then you can do-- for so
whether that's the point of inflection
or not I don't know right now okay right
that's when it'll issues negative the
rest of it is acceleration positive okay
now this is a fun question they want to
know whether when is the displacement
velocity and speed not acceleration when
are these similar to time - okay so
where is time to time
okay so that point there represents a
point I'm okay and they'll want to know
where's it's similar like what is the
displacement similar to that point
okay well displacement is represented by
this vertical axis so I can slice the
line across this okay so any points
which collide with that line right they
have the same displacement at when time
equals two okay so where would you guess
these points are I mean it's just a
guess it's just approximately but what
do you reckon where we got over here
probably one unit to the right maybe so
maybe time for okay but there's another
point isn't there over here on the my
graph it's pretty close to Teague was 12
not exactly sure your graph it might
actually be a little bit different
I'm just looking at maybe you might say
T equals 10 depends on the drawing of
your graph okay but again the point is
you judge it based on the drawing
that's where the displacement is civil
up to that point what about the velocity
is there a point that matches this kind
of velocity it's moving to the right it
has to be moving to the right because
velocity includes direction right and to
match its steepness you can sort of draw
a tangent later
so are there any other points of the
graph where the tangent would be
parallel to that and the answer is yeah
I'm I'm looking it'll be somewhere along
this part won't it okay obviously it
can't be any part in here because the
tension would be only in the opposite
direction moving to the left somewhere
on here and again it depends on your
drawing
okay so might be it might even be that
same point over there okay so I might
say last one here they asked in graph
but I think you guys can do it on your
own they asked about speed what
difference does that make to Vossen
because you know they convicted right it
means you can also consider going at the
same steepness but in the opposite
direction right so I guess that would
mean
you know for instance suppose my grade
EQ was - okay so that would be velocity
2 meters to the right okay per second
well this line over here right that
point what's still beat should be this
per second it's just going in the other
direction but the spades the same right
this would be 2 meters per second to the
right and this would be 2 meters per
second to the left right but I don't
care about direction if I'm like just
thinking about speed okay
so speed by the way I guess if you want
to think about it that way
speed is the absolute value of the
derivative that's what speed is isn't it
okay and so we've got we've got those
two points there what they say something
like 4 and of course the original one
because so you can see how much
information you can just read off a
graph okay so you need to get really
used to growing it well and being able
to interpret it rather than relying on
your algebra like I didn't appeal to
well I almost never appealed to algebra
really and even when I did I said well
now look at what that means
geometrically okay in case I haven't
have it into your head [ __ ] draw B
graphs for these they will repay you
when you spend the time okay